personne libéré mais toujours en flamme
se termina le pétrolier a été bombardé
par les forces russes ce samedi symbole
que le front n'est pas très loin et la
guerre pas terminée mais ici la vie
reprend peu à peu son cours devant ce
supermarché la file d'attente s'étend
sur des dizaines de mètres et pour cause
c'est la première fois que
l'établissement rouvre depuis la
libération de la ville l'enseigne a été
entièrement réapprovisionnée ici il y a
mes produits Ukrainiens préférés depuis
février nous n'avions que des magasins
et des marchandises russes par principe
nous n'achetions rien de tout ça
les prix étaient trois fois plus élevés
même plus de trois fois selon les
marchandises
et beaucoup de choses n'étaient pas
disponibles
le retour à la normale et lui encore
bien lointain dans la ville tout est à
reconstruire l'aéroport par exemple
ressemble à un vaste cimetière militaire
un peu plus loin ces équipes de
démineurs continuent d'inspecter chaque
maison chaque terrain le travail est
colossal mais avance petit à petit selon
les autorités
les services administratifs sont
rétablis le centre de services
administratif fonctionne maintenant
désormais nous travaillons à rétablir le
réseau cellulaire et le système
financier
à l'approche du cœur de l'hiver les
habitants de Kerson restent privés d'eau
d'électricité et la situation devrait
encore durer